Hello,
and welcome
to today's episode of Clustered.
Today's a bit different than normal.
Today is
Clustered versus Rawkode versus the community.
Not really sure how it's gonna work,
but let me share some stuff with you.
First,
check out Rawkode.live.
That is the YouTube channel. Please subscribe.
Click the bell.
You'll get alerts and notifications for all new
episodes of Clustered, as well as all new
episodes
where I explore cloud native products and technologies
with their founders and make this all a
little bit easier for us all.
There's also a Discord server available at Rawkode.chat.
There's nearly 500 of us on there now
talking all things cloud native Kubernetes
and everything in between.
I started doing something a little bit different
lately, and I'm giving away a lot of
swag.
Some people have asked, what if I just
wanna buy a t shirt and support it?
So I have included
the link there. So please feel free to
check out store.rawco.com.
But also, I will be giving away lots
of swag over the next weeks and months.
So stay tuned, enjoy the episodes,
and I hope you get to win something.
There's a couple of little links on this
site there.
So
custard.live
is a thing that I threw together
literally in the last couple of days to
try and make our streams more interactive and
more engaging and give you an opportunity to
win.
It was painful
fighting with the Twitter API,
but we do have something that works, and
I'll walk you through that in just a
moment.
Today's episode is
Versys episode with myself.
So we have a cluster broken by some
regulars.
You may know no
or fresbo and
Russell w.
I had a third cluster, which I asked
someone to break, but unfortunately, due to constraints,
time, and,
well,
life,
it wasn't able to be broken in time
for today's episode. So you'll also notice here,
there is a Rawkode.live/destroy-
it.
This is a public
KubeConfig
to a Kubernetes cluster
running on Equinix metal.
My challenge to you lot
is go fuck with it.
I will be using
well, I will be blocking access to it
very soon.
But for the next thirty minutes, feel free
to try and break it as you wish.
I also want to thank Teleport for sponsoring,
sponsoring custard.
You know, I've been using Teleport since the
first episode. I think it's an absolutely fantastic
product. It's just wonderful that I get to
use it on the stream every week and
get to show you all how cool it
is. So you should go check it out.
They support the show. They're providing the swag.
They're the ones that are making all of
this, all of these giveaways possible. So thank
you to Teleport.
To support the show, go to raw Rawkode
Live / Teleport.
It is a UTM link, but it just
means that they have a little bit of
feedback that shows, you know, supporting
this channel works for them.
That's quite a lot of talk for the
start of this episode. I'm also very nervous
about this episode because I'm fixing things alone,
so I do have a beer.
Okay. Let's take a look at today.
This is clustered.live.
Let me remove our sponsor message for the
time being,
where we can click
saying I'm with Twitter.
Now there have been a few people that
have mentioned that the permissions
to access this application
are a little
permissive, but unfortunately, the Twitter API only really
exposes read or read write. There is nothing
in between. So I'm really sorry about that,
but it is the best that we can
do.
I also ask for those permissions because when
you enter the competition,
it will
follow my account, follow the Teleport account, and
repeat retweet the tweet. Now I don't see
it here because I've already entered,
but there is lots of warning messages. I'm
not doing this without your permission.
I hope you understand that. It's really just
a workaround the Twitter API and the fact
that I can't check,
painfully cannot check if you follow an account
or if you have re tweeted a tweet.
I cannot stress it enough. This is not
the way that I wanted this to go,
but it's the best that I could come
up with at least in this amount of
time. So I'm gonna try and make this
better, but if you do want to win
some swag today, we have three Rawkode swag
packs, we have three Teleport swag packs, and
we have 10 copies of Siam Patak's
SKS training manual.
So enter the competition. Your odds are really,
really good of winning. Right? We've got ten,
thirteen,
six
16 prizes, and we don't even have 16
entries yet. So chances are click that button
and you can win something today.
Rawkode.live/destroyit
will take you to this guest where there
is a KubeConfig.
Download it, attack the cluster. I'll be getting
to that in around thirty minutes time.
And also, I know the permissions on my
application are
a bit wild. They allow me to upgrade
your profile. They allowed me to delete your
account, I think. There's a whole bunch of
things. Again,
not by choice, but the code for all
of it is open source. You can find
that at github.com/rockodeacademy/clustered.live.
Cool.
Today,
we are gonna fix some clusters.
So I have three here.
We're gonna start with Russell w's cluster. So
thank you for taking the time out of
your day to break this.
What I'm gonna do
is
start my timer.
There we go.
And zoom in.
Oh, hold on a minute. Why have I
given myself four or five minutes? Alright. We'll
do what I can.
I actually have much less than four to
five minutes per cluster because I have three.
So really, I've got, twenty minutes per cluster.
And I can't really keep up with the
chat and all the talking,
so I'll try and keep my eye out
there. Who broke Teleport?
Come on, Kevin.
You're not allowed to break Teleport.
You're also telling me it's a Twitter page.
It's absolute shame.
Awful. Cannot stand it.
Okay.
Let's see what we've got.
The reason I'm starting with Brussels because I
did look at nulls and notice we don't
even have any worker nodes. I'm gonna come
back to that one. Instead, we'll start with
this one.
We'll log on to the admin account
and I'll export my kube config.
Alias key
and I run get notes.
Alright. I have no control plan. Thank you,
Russell.
Need a bigger drink.
Okay. So what do we do when we
have no control plan?
First thing I'm gonna do
is check our kubelet.
I can see the service is loaded, but
it is stopped.
I'm gonna try just starting that back up.
And while that starts, I'm gonna jump into
our Kubernetes manifest. Thanks.
Thanks, Russell.
I hope you scripted that.
Have yourself for each break.
Yeah. It may go that way now.
I don't have any static manifests.
They all appear
to be the same number of baits.
Think they're all
alright. Okay.
They're not all the same number of bytes.
The letters are the same number of bytes.
So I think
a, b,
c,
d, and e
are the fails I need and everything else
is noise.
Alright.
I am gonna move
a, b, c, d, e
dot yaml
to temp
run ls.
Yep.
And I don't trust,
I don't need these. So we'll call this
dumping ground.
Gonna move everything to our dumping ground.
We're gonna move everything back.
YAML
to here.
Where did that Selen come from?
Good thing that's mine, I'm gonna push that
back.
Okay.
Now we have a, b, c, d, e,
and e. Yaml. I'm actually not fussed about
the names. I just wanna make sure I've
got the right components. So in fact, we'll
just
star.yaml.
So we've got our API server,
etcd
controller manager, scheduler,
kubect.
Okay.
Hopefully
that gets me a control plane online.
I guess what we want to see now
is do we have
an API server?
Do we have a controller?
Not quite. Do we have an actual working
kubelet yet?
No. Okay. So our kubelet is broken.
I'm gonna take a look at our kubelet
logs
and it is misconfigured.
Okay.
We shouldn't have an Etsy kubelet fail.
We're gonna go into our with the system,
system control
cat,
kuplet,
and we're going to check
and make sure there's nothing weird here.
Exact start here has been tampered with,
and that is in this drop in here.
Our kubelet should be in user
ben
user ben kuplet, maybe user ben local kuplet.
User ben kuplet,
the daemon reload,
restart
kuplet.
And we'll take a look at those logs
and that looks a bit better.
Hopefully those errors go away.
Let's see what we've got in the chat
so far.
Yeah. Well, brought an account then during the
team stuff
just to make sure that he gave appropriate
time to each of the clusters that we
have. So it's it's really more of a
guide. It's not always enforced, but
yeah. I try to keep it there.
Some love for Russell's break. People laughing.
I'm
not laughing.
That's a lot of yaml. Lots of alright.
Okay. Selim was not you, Russell. Thank you.
That helps. I'm not sure why that Selim.YAML
was there.
You're a gentleman. Okay. So we do have
hints if we need them and slash root
hints.
Okay.
I'm curious
if we have an API server. We do
not.
Controller,
cube. All right, we've got a few things.
So now our API server is failing.
We can go to varlog containers
and we can tail
cube API server,
and it's been shut down.
Structural
schema condition controller.
Interesting.
Oh, yeah. They're called funny names.
Alright. Let's see. API server, advertise address, low
privileged
authorization
mode.
All fine, fine, fine. Admission plugins, no destruction
is okay.
LCD
should be alright. It should check that it's
running though.
And
that looks alright.
Not sure about the probes. Hard coded IP
address is probably a private IP before that
machine,
not something I often look at. I'm gonna
assume it's all right.
I'm not sure if we should have a
default seccomp profile on API server,
but
I can't think of this just running on
a web server. Yeah. It should should be
alright. It's not scheduling anything.
Okay. That looked alright. So I
because I'm confused,
I'm gonna take a look
cdb at the top. Not probably a good
sign, right?
Yeah,
think I'm just okay.
Okay.
Let's see, kubectl.
Look at this in a bit more detail.
When's this last
start? This is sixteen o two. Hey, that's
a while ago.
So we're starting here.
Oh, we got a shutdown
here. How can I shut down before it
starts?
Yes.
That's funny.
I'm not in there.
Okay.
It could be API server, a control plane.
It looks
looks fine.
I can never remember this stuff. Oh, no.
It is the crisis here.
Runtime endpoint.
Okay. API server four minutes ago.
Let me do logs.
Container ID. All right. Okay. So we can
do logs, but we need
ps and
then log
on our API servers dot again. Okay.
Strange.
I guess this is just the pod shows
because the pod is created even though the
container doesn't exist.
I
move
fail.
Just try and encourage the kubelet to reschedule
it.
K.
So the KubePad errors are because it can't
speak to the API server,
But I'm not seeing one.
Start.
I'm not getting any more logs.
I'm gonna restart
Kubler.
I really wanna see this Kube API server
failable too. So I'm just gonna remove it,
which I'm gonna regret in five minutes.
Watch.
And we'll wait for that fail to come
back, see if we can get some more
logs out of that API server. I'm not
sure what is happening here at the moment,
but I'm doing okay for time, I think.
Russell is just happy it took more than
five minutes.
You know, people always worry when I invite
them on to break clusters that their effects
are too superficial.
It just doesn't work that way. It's
really hard debugging clusters.
I'll see that because I'm doing one.
The kubelet is running. We're still almost again.
Add our messages here.
And I wanna be able to filter that.
So let's remove
the follow.
Search for API.
Okay. So fail is creating a matter of
pod.
I finally got something that looks like it's
useful
and it's failing because the pod already exists.
Yeah. So we did see that behavior with
the CryoControl PS.
That's it was created a few minutes ago.
I suspect that's gonna be even
newer now. No.
Is that RMP?
So I've removed that pod.
Let's see if it comes back.
Yep.
Nope.
No API server logs.
Kipla.
What's happening just now?
Okay.
So,
okay. So we've got API server crash loop
back off.
And there's a component skipping field to start
container for the cube API server with a
crash loop back off. Okay.
Then why am I not getting logs?
That's a good idea, Kevin. I think I
will take a hint. I'm gonna take a
look at our IPS. I'm gonna take a
look this one more time
because I feel
Why are we not getting logs?
Okay.
Is that a directory? Yep.
Okay. So we're past the beach.
What's the second ten? Oh, there's a read
me. Okay.
Welcome to oh, you never told me there
was a bag story. Okay. So welcome to
the Crystal Maze Cluster. You will need to
travel through four zones in order to solve
their puzzles. Good luck. I hope it's challenging
enough without being too frustrating.
Well, you failed. It's frustrating. Let's begin. Picture
zone. If you want hints, I'll just drive
straight in. Beach. Just a view of the
beach. Yeah. We we we've done the beach.
So I don't think this is
the industrial networking one.
Something with the stairs and then
there is a phrase you can't see the
wood for the trees.
Yeah. I don't want you to start opening
all these hints, Russell. So
which one which hint should I look at
for the API server break?
Give me a heads up.
And I'll think.
Really annoying me if there's more logs.
I need to know why it's breaking.
Must be something in here.
Okay. Trees.
Thank you, Russell.
The forest.
Oh, we got a couple of hints here.
Okay,
so many questions, which fails do you need
to edit? However, there's many fails in the
static manifest directory, but only a few containers
being run.
Where is the API server? Right, well,
I think I fixed the first part of
the forest.
Ah, sneaky.
Very sneaky.
Alright. Well, I do not need any of
your aliases.
Should have paid more attention to them now
that I've just deleted them all
because I wasn't actually sure what you were
doing. It looks like you were just intercepting
my LS and CD,
which I meant, I thought you had modified
my
manifest directory.
Yeah. It was far too quick to delete
those aliases. I should have paid attention.
Okay. It was intercepted in CD and LS.
I now know I've got the proper LS.
We're take another hint just because I deleted
that stuff too quickly.
I shouldn't have to log in or nor
log out.
So I don't think you'd maybe change the
manifest. That's why I did that. The
cat on the couplet, and I was gonna
start poking around to see if you'd maybe
told it to live in a different location.
Let's take a look.
There we
And you know I should have trusted my
gut.
Okay.
This is the actual static manifesto retro.
API server.
Good.
I I I don't think there's anything wrong
with that API server.
Got me going around in circles here.
We've got twenty minutes left.
Might as well read all the forest hence
while we're here.
So this one was the battery aliases. We
found the real manifest.
So yes, I am frustrated.
I did try calling user Ben.
Okay, so you basically broken
everything is what you're telling me.
This is definitely this.
That's the same.
And I still have
Kube API server that I think is all
right.
Oh, you're telling me there's two problems in
this API site. Thank you, Russell.
Okay.
Line by line and stop rushing.
So there's definitely a direct command, advertiser address.
Should be okay.
I have IPv4.
Okay. User thing.
Hoping it'll have to check all the cert
paths.
Secure port is okay.
There we go.
Unless that is the poor. I've just never
noticed that before.
I don't even know if that's a fixer.
I'm breaking it more.
I wonder
if I couldn't see logs because of that
CD intercept.
Maybe that was an old log.
I still don't have any API.
Okay. Well, the probe ports,
the two issues in that spec.
Oh, this is wrong too.
All the ports are wrong.
Okay.
Let's try that.
Log yet.
We start in a kubelet.
I hate you.
Alright.
I'm just gonna keep restarting the cubelet till
I get an API server.
Why is it not taping?
Teleport was broken.
What have I done?
Cool department up.
We have an API server at least.
And
I don't know if I broke
Teleport or,
Okay. Don't know what happened there.
Okay. Let's
export.
Yes.
It pods.
I think they've been
cordoned.
Nope.
Okay.
So Russell says that's forest and cryptography
covered. It's just the industrial stage now.
So
let's see. These are gonna wait.
Worker one, worker one,
worker two,
worker one. Okay. So I
think your readme suggested that everything is on
the control plane.
I've not touched the worker nodes at all.
Okay.
Let's see if we've got any
10x rules. We don't.
We are, these clusters are all one twenty
two.
No.
Started provisioning them the day after release.
Okay. So
we've got some networking problem.
And what we can do,
see if we can get any
logs from this pod here.
Unable to reach the API server that may
just need,
oh, come down.
May just need a wee nudge.
And
nudge.
Okay. Let's see if that's something that's happy
again.
I wonder if that's the same reason the
ambassador is potentially broken.
I will just start rotating pods.
Let's see.
Okay. That's definitely healthier.
So that means I could do a k
get
deployments
and deployments
clustered
image
two.
Let's see if that works.
And it did.
Let's see what happens.
And I've got the dance.
So I'm not sure what your industrial problem
was, Russell, but it did not stop me
from deploying version two.
Alright.
Cluster fix. Thank you, Russell. That was infuriating,
but very good.
Yeah. The bash alias is that, you know,
I just don't even
I don't think, you know, there's nothing, there's
no feedback to let you know
that you're working with any leads or anything
like that. So yeah, maybe something I should
start checking by default
in the future.
Yeah. And that image
sneaky.
Okay.
Let's jump on to node cluster,
which isn't looking very healthy at the moment.
We have no worker nodes.
Alias, k, control.
At least I'm getting real LAS CDs are
built in.
Okay.
K. Get notes.
Which kip control.
It's CTL.
Looks all right.
Version.
I've got an API server.
But something.
We have no apps we want our core
v one.
Okay.
So how would this be possible? Well,
we're going straight back to our static manifest.
We're taking a look at our API server
configuration.
Disappointed in my cursor did not start halfway
down the file.
Do we have all our controllers running?
Certainly looks like it
didn't start my timer.
There you go.
I mean, you could have reset the times
on the files, of course, but
it looks clean.
Double check the image.
We're getting bit by that twice.
Okay.
So
either I don't have access
to these types.
Okay. Let's get
cluster
roles.
Hopefully it's not
our back. Please don't be our back.
So
I have my admin account.
Let's take a look at the context for
Kubernetes admin.
Speaking to the correct cluster.
Cluster admin here.
Not our back.
That's good.
That was the only lead I had. No.
So
let's check.
Make sure this matches what we can expect
it to see from the static pod manifest.
No sneaky static admission controllers,
no controllers being disabled.
Okay.
I should have brought two beers to this
episode.
Okay.
How are you removing pods?
How are you to moving pods?
Okay. Let's roll that out. What do we
have access to?
I'm able to retrieve the complete list of
server APIs. Apps v one, the server could
not How did you remove apps to be
one? And where's core of e one?
I've never seen that before.
I'm impressed.
Shit.
I mean,
it has to be
it has to be API server.
Unless she did something in the cluster and
then out of the cluster.
You know what? I think I'm I'm gonna
have to reach for a hintel.
Okay. So the APIs
have decided to play hide and seek.
Where have they gone?
Nasty Goose.
That's a hint.
This is sneaky.
Okay. So you could have modified kubectl,
even though it's a binary.
May not be
the correct one.
It does to get tree state clean.
Make sure I'm calling this kubectl.
I am calling this kubectl.
Do we have any other kubectl?
Shooter,
Ben.
This is too funny.
There it is.
Runtime config v one equals false and ask
v one equals false. Okay.
So I can see it here.
Runtime,
but not there.
You've moved the stack there. You've done the
same, right?
So let's take a look
and our config
here.
It's not been moved.
The static pod manifest is the same.
How is that run
time config again
and to the API server?
What if it's not running as a static
pod?
Alright.
It's
definitely not an as fail, right?
Okay.
So it could be
there's two static manifests
and one of these fails.
No.
I like this.
I could see
the problem.
Do we trust a Qublet?
And those tell me to read the hints
again.
Okay.
The API is to say play hide and
seek. Where have they gone? Those are nasty
gifts. Don't worry. Let me think. I'm
trying to think my kubelet is not a
kubelet.
Know I should go to directory here.
Can't really tell what you were building.
I should have hidden it from PS as
well. This is also a hint.
You all are cruel.
Okay. So we could be in a position
where
our API server scheduled by the kubelet just
isn't running.
That may be the case because
got it. Okay.
So that's nice. Our Kubelet can't actually schedule
the API server via container D because the
port has already been bound.
So no has managed to
I mean, I don't think system D and
I took a look in the system D
directory, but I guess it's been a lot
more sneaky
than that,
which means
in theory,
I could probably just kill this process.
No, it came straight back.
I'm gonna stop the cube there.
I'm gonna kill
this.
It's gone.
Install,
install,
reinstall,
kubelet.
If you hacked my kubelet.
That's taken a little bit longer than I
was kind of expecting it to, but that's
good or bad.
There we go.
And And then I'm going to restart the
Kubelet. I'm going to assume you compare join
Kubelet to spin up its own API server
before running a static MatterPods.
I think that's maybe what you've done.
No.
Darn it.
Okay, I'm gonna stop the Kubelet again. I
wanna confirm
that kubelet is definitely starting this process.
Desperation
on the Linux command.
Container
D.
I think that is actually just part of
CTR.
Okay. That's a pretty big hint.
Noel says, do you trust the manifest fails
that you see?
I mean, I think so.
Okay. So you've not done something through a
shell.
This better not be eBPF.
Do I trust the manifest files I see?
Okay. The API server does have an extra
line in it.
It's kinda what I think you're telling me.
But I can't see it.
I hate computers.
I may have asked
stop my QP.
The kubelet.com
should just be the
user to connect to it.
I don't think there would be anything in
there.
Seems normal.
Woodworking is a great idea.
Okay.
So
I have no idea.
I'm curious what happens if I add desktop.
I don't think it's adding. Let's
kill the process to be sure.
I think this has to be BPS and
there's no way to debug that.
Have I broke it?
It's not getting my flags I added either.
You've stumped me now. Tell me what it
is.
I just don't know where to start now.
So you're gonna have to
I don't know how to use BPF tool.
And here is the though.
Russell, I did add a new param to
the gamble. It didn't show up.
But I I I don't know. So Nolan
said he left tool,
which means
there is an eBPF hack in somewhere.
No. No more hunch, just tell us.
Do
I trust the off system into the nodes
teleport?
Not particularly. You tell me I can SSH
in manually.
You're saying run system control cat teleport d.
Okay. So you're using VARTEP EPPF kit.
The source, so there's a Rawkode Kube API
server manifest in VARTEP,
which is targeting a fail over there.
So
you've got an eBPF
probe that whenever the kubelet tries to access
the kubelet server YAML and save them the
manifest directory,
you're actually redirecting
it to var
temp.
Was that supposed to happen?
Alright. I'm gonna just kill it.
It does not like that. Stop the kubelet.
Kill the process
of our temp.
Oh yeah, it does not like me doing
that.
Oh, you have to, okay, got it. So
no, and the chat is saying I'll have
to
stop the teleport the process with the eBPF
kit.
That's nicest of eBPF
and really difficult to track down.
I think it's fair to say that eBPF
is a devil's work.
Let's jump back over to here just now.
I really, what I should have done at
some point
is run a status
and take a look at everything in this
list.
And I would have spotted our phony teleportee.
I think
think I would have spotted it.
So there we go. Couple of learnings
there. Always take a look at the system,
process table service list
and never let Noel and Russell near cluster
again.
Yeah. I don't know what's happening here, so
I'm just going to leave.
And I'm gonna assume that eBPF kit is
not gonna show up here. I'm curious how
you had that,
But we'll just leave it. That was tricky.
Really, really tricky. Good work, Noel.
Alright. I gave you all access to this
cluster. I don't know if anyone has access
to machine.
I don't know if anyone's run or no
one's
SSH channel would give you access to.
All right, I have removed.
Yeah, Waleed, thanks for joining us.
We'll
quickly check if anyone did anything to this
cluster.
And if not, we'll call it an eight.
There has been a guess.
Alright.
Guess I'm fixing one more.
Alright. We have a kubelet.
I have an API server.
It's got secure port six six three.
I bet there's nothing wrong with this cluster
except for me.
I didn't do the export properly.
Yeah.
Well, maybe someone did break something. Okay.
Well, let's see why our application
is crashing.
There's no logs on that, of course. I
should know that by now.
Someone changed the label.
Sneaky.
Although, maybe it's here. So maybe it's a
typo in my automation. That would be funny.
Let's just bump it up to V2
always.
Oh, someone's changed the probes.
Can't remember the ports on this application.
I think it's eighty eighty.
And here,
a death by a thousand cuts I can
see.
And resource limits look okay.
And what do we get here?
Okay, I can't change the labels, so maybe
that is part of my
automation.
Fix that back.
Let's see what happens.
Okay,
the probes aren't passing. That's typically what the
internal server error means.
It does look okay.
Maybe I should expect to
No, it's broken.
Okay.
Let's
see.
It should be a node port service.
Maybe someone's modified that too.
Selector is wrong. Okay. So I think someone
actually deleted that deployment and you applied it
with the broken labels. So it's probably not
my automation.
And we've got an endpoint now.
Is that healthier? I think that's healthier.
Possibly gonna time out because,
Postgres
does have endpoints.
What happens if I curl?
Okay. What's wrong with my application?
And see, don't even know who to ask
for help now.
I actually think if we pull up my
automation,
I think it just runs on port 80.
I don't think it has eighty eighty at
all, but I could be
could be wrong.
No, it's okay.
Or 88.
Okay,
so what is wrong?
Clustered.
We've got an endpoint.
It's running.
But I'm not really able to
do anything.
So let's
try
getting a shell.
Let's see what happens. Let's see if gonna
time out from the database
or something else.
Failed to connect to the base. Okay. So,
alright, can it resolve?
No. Okay.
So
get pods all. Where's core DNS?
It is running.
Let's see if it is broken DNS
and everything.
I don't know if that's resolving.
No.
Okay. I have no networking.
So it's probably not DNS.
Never said that before
and possibly that I just can't
create a DNS within the cluster.
Okay. Host is fine.
Selim appears to be okay.
I'm kinda running out of time because I
do have a hard stop, but I'll see
how far I can get through this.
If anybody made changes to this cluster and
you're still watching, drop a message in
the chat
and maybe we can speed this up a
little bit.
Okay. So
Wonder if someone just applied cluster policies
rather than modifying the config map. Because modifying
the config map would be a bit mean.
There we go.
See, sometimes you make it more difficult for
yourself by looking into like, oh, they could
have broken suddenly when it can just be
the really,
really, really simple things.
Okay. So we've got some swag to give
away.
And thank you to anyone who
broke that cluster.
That was a nice easy one, which is
appreciated
after those two car crashes that we had.
And what do we need to do? Well,
we need to go to Rawkode Academy clustered
live.
So like I said, this repository is all
online.
We can run
chicken dinner.
And we'll see we have 19 participants in
today's competition.
I can stop by the timer now. We
don't need that. Right. There we go.
And we have 10 winners. So thank you
to our sponsor Teleport
who are providing
copies of SIAM's CTS book,
and they are providing three vouchers
for swag.
I am also gonna be giving away three
Rawkode t shirts. So in total, we are
looking for 16 winners today.
The way this is gonna work
is the script just doesn't, you know, it's
it's
I need to be able to run it
like so. It's just gonna spell 16 names.
So what I'm gonna say is the first
three names get the Rawkode t shirts.
The next three names will get the teleport
swag,
and the final 10 names will get the
CKS
book.
Hopefully, you all are happy with that. I
will make the code around this competition a
bit more sophisticated over the next days and
weeks, but it just needs a bit more
time. This is what I could put on
very quickly,
and I'm gonna go back to fighting the
Twitter API very soon.
So
Python three chicken dinner, 16 winners, please. Only
three if you're not gonna win. I'm I'm
really sorry about that,
but
that's that's the way the cookie crumbles.
Okay. Rawkode T shirts go to Walid.
Just me and open source and Crux.
We have Teleport Swag for Noel, Kevin, and
Rishba,
and oh, I won. I'm gonna have to
draw one more.
The Meric, Russell,
Safiya Safiya.
I'm not sure.
Adriyasha,
Roberto,
Jason, Philip, Steve, and Atnish. So I will
save these
to our winners. I will draw one more
because I obviously don't want to win.
I'm gonna move the sponsor message just now.
And hopefully we don't get a repeat name.
Sid Palas, there you go, Sid DevOps directive.
You have also won
CTS book.
So there is our winners.
Thank you everyone.
That's SASSA. Awesome.
No worries.
I'll reach out. I have all your Twitter
handles, which are stored in Firebase. I will
drop you a DM. We will organize your
swag, and we will be doing this every
week on Clustard, so make sure you come
back.
We're also looking for more people to compete
on Clustard
and more teams. So if you wanna come
on and have some fun, regardless of your
level of skill or experience with Kubernetes,
we'll find a way to get you on
and have some fun with this. So
drop me a DM on Twitter, say if
you want to join solo or teams or
both, and we'll do our best to make
that happen.
I'm gonna give one final thank you to
Teleport for their support and for letting us
give away some swag.
And I am going to say goodbye, and
I will see you all later. So thanks
for joining us. Have a wonderful day, and
I'll speak to you all soon. Bye.